[Music]
in controversial arrest news submitted
by Wilbur a woman was arrested after
turning her husband's guns into the
police oh I think this was so funny yeah
doesn't like totally backfired Oh a 33
year old woman she it was a victim of
some crazy show of her husband so dad
split up
her husband was ramming his car into her
car so she was fearful of her life so he
was charged with domestic violence and
attempting to run her over with his car
and so she once he got arrested she went
into his home and took his firearms away
turned him in to the police and said
here he's not gonna turn them in because
he's supposed to once he's charged with
that she said he's not gonna do this I'm
scared for my life so I went into his
apartment when it was locked and he he
locked up so without his permission I
went in there and then so the cops is
saying like wait so you're telling me
you committed an armed burglary and she
said yes I am but he wasn't gonna turn
them in so I'm doing it so then she was
arrested
that's a mess yeah that sucks because
it's kind of self-righteous like yeah
how did you know that he wasn't gonna do
it well I mean it doesn't sound so it
just sounds like she's really scared
yeah he has a history of being really
violent so she did not think that he was
going to be like oh yes I'm a violent
person but here my gun I mean it just
sounds like um maybe she presented it
wrong but it really just sounds like I'm
trying to protect myself and heat like
he's since he's not gonna turn this and
he's probably gonna use these against
I actually don't don't hear that well
yeah what I hear from me is that she's
actually really vengeful and I don't
think she's actually scared for her life
cuz she's turning on the wrong weapon he
was trying to run her over with the car
and I think for her she's like okay how
can I get this [ __ ] back this
month I've seen I've been in
relationships like this and I've seen
relationships like this one with dating
a bunch of hood rats they'll play the
game Oh [ __ ] so scared
oh this walls gonna beat my ass from the
cops
come around but they just want to get
what the next vengeful move so she's
probably like oh this [ __ ] wants
to run me over I'll get his guns taken
away yep and then so can you read all
that if you really are scared of someone
you would not dare to even take one step
against them well but he was in jail
yeah how she did that during a
psychological JIT you know the people
the girls or even guys are able to be
controlled when their man is still in
jail yeah I think she ain't saying [ __ ]
like dude your husband has is doing 30
years to life
it's a brave move yeah it's really brave
for someone that's really fearing her
life cuz if I was in her position and I
was [ __ ] scared I would just tell the
cops like this person is armed and all
that and I would leave town yeah I would
never again I would run away like it's a
bold move to break into someone's place
and they know that you did it and they
can get you after and all that yeah damn
you guys are hood rats or so can we see
what they look like that's a good
question I'm picturing something as well
pretty much hmm wait a minute
they're kind of cute for that kind of be
through the native people of Alabama the
cute for that kind of behavior they
don't what does that mean you look messy
to me yeah what are you talking about
why don't they look messy no messy messy
is usually okay
usually when you when you think of the
damn bear like you think mess like a
banjo yeah brother take me back I'm
gonna [ __ ] my sister like you think I'm
mad you think and you think really like
trashy look I think they were trashy of
how they don't look like Walmart they
look like Mervyn's okay
Mervin like a big lot oh yeah yeah so
they're not
country a little bit rock and haul yeah
I forgot that exist
yeah okay okay a place in Florida in
case you guys were wondering of course I
was close Lauretta Floridian typical and
so this went viral because they're
saying like how can you punish the
victim she was just trying to protect
herself
breaking mentoring math is a serious
crime well now the way Bart pitched it
he like really changed my mind on it
because I'm like watch I was with I was
with that like I was with the the mast
is going like dude that's [ __ ] up now
she should go to jail fearing for her
life I mean I'm not blaming the victim
I'm not blaming it's [ __ ] up that her
boyfriend is trying to run her over like
I don't believe in any domestic violence
or abuse or any husband but but I've
seen enough reality to know who she is
as well and she's not as much of a
victim my experience not as much as a
victim as she claimed Geo
why isn't she a victim and you're being
oh I didn't say she wasn't a victim but
just the way I was looking at it was Dan
that's [ __ ] up she really does fear
for her life so it makes sense that she
burglarized this apartment got the guns
in and turned it in
but now hearing how he's had his life
experiences or whatever someone that's
fearing for their life that is a very
bold move so yeah that's [ __ ] up
whatever happened to her and her
husband's trying to do like that for
sure is [ __ ] up I don't condone that
what--what's didn't live together no
that only thing they're separated yeah
but if she knows he's working her some
[ __ ] she could go rob his house and
probably feel pretty safe that he's not
gonna be there yeah that's what I was
thinking yeah but the way he painted in
winter skills I put myself in the
situation of like [ __ ] if I was getting
abused and I was in that like I don't
know what he would be capable of and if
I knew he had guns and I would say hey
you know what police um he is arrested
but I know he has some firearms go go
check his [ __ ] wait
so he's supposed to turn in his guns is
that what happened mm-hm
he's supposed to turn in his guns like
once you are a domestic abuser Oh
we obtained you're gonna know he's found
guilty yeah and then at that point he
has to turn in his gun yeah but at that
point he went to jail and so she was
afraid that when he comes out of jail
we're gonna retaliate yeah yeah oh so
they are saying that it's up to local
law enforcement to enforce that law
they're gonna forget though so I guess
that's what she felt like she was that
scared that she had to take matters into
her own hands but now you know she got
arrested what do you think Kingsley yes
I know he's stupid
I just I I agree I think she might have
feared for her life but either way she's
dumb for braking and like taking it her
solace yeah you can't break them all she
she should have burned down his
apartment now that's smart arson is you
just burn that [ __ ] down let's charge
an arm drop you know God's no nobody can
use it they're melted into nickel yep or
just an odd yeah anonymously like drop
it out drop it on the [ __ ] police
station scratch off the serial what did
the [ __ ] come from cuz then I think now
when he gets out of jail do they have to
give him back the guns or no because he
has a felony no it's not allowed to just
own it anymore she should just put a box
on them on the pork yeah Lee station
that's a - please enjoy these guns she's
too honorable yeah just like that's
right I did it it's like just you should
have left it there like a baby out of a
cannon fire hired Fire Department yeah
yeah baby had a fire if you put them
next to a fire hydrant they have to take
it yeah or else the dogs gonna pee on a
baby so you don't want that to happen
yeah we don't yeah have you guys ever
done anything that you thought was the
right thing and then it backfires though
right yeah I told my mom the truth that
should be Mass about what she always
says if you tell me the truth I won't
get mad I promise I told her the truth
get my ass beat her more than once yeah
cuz I think she's supposed to help me
cuz she want her to keep her word yeah
and she's my mom but she just kept lying
to me I bet you your mom felt that way
but when she heard what you did yes
was like what [ __ ] that she just like
lost it yeah I don't I feel like uh I
guess one that pops in my head that's
like well you're trying to do the right
thing but you're just Delma body and it
backfires it's like why no girl is
looking in the mirror and they're just
like oh man you know like maybe I can
lose a little weight and then the guys
like yeah maybe you could maybe you
should go and work out I'm like but
isn't that the guy getting your back you
tried it backfires in the sense where
like you didn't make me feel better it
made me feel worse now you got to work
out how about the guy guy so you want
the guy to disagree with you yes yes yes
yes
okay what's the age-old thing right like
so this always happens in a couple we're
like the girlfriend or be like wife
would be like honey I think I'm getting
fat right and then like what what are
they looking for they're looking for
compliments yes let's go work out baby
no no I don't want you to go this
mirrors broken you look skinny I went
too far you can't have me and then
you're like maybe science will invent a
mirror that finds you attractive and we
should donate to a science pretty good
what if you did gain 60 pounds Wow well
listen what don't you want KC to be like
you aren't bad as [ __ ] can answer your
question you think we're blind enough to
not know that we gain 60 yeah girls got
body to support dysmorphia know we tell
girls are hot as hell and they still
have problems with themselves but if we
gain 60 pounds we're well aware that we
gained 60 pounds so if we're going do we
look fat it's like what we're really
saying and we don't know why we don't
say it's true yeah oh we're really
saying is please tell me I'm beautiful
you haven't set it off
there's nothing more stressful to me
than when I get asked these questions
because I don't know what the right
thing is to say yeah
Nikki's like she's standing on the scale
right and it says plus 60 plus 60 in
jiggles hey how much did how much more
do I weigh and look about the scale this
is 60 60 years ten no we're supposed to
live no we wouldn't ask that stupid
question plus 60
read the questions this it's like it
only tells you how much you gain you can
tell me like in another occasion not in
that moment when I'm asking like I'm
trying to fish force themselves oh no
confidence dogfish a it could be a done
differently
what are you telling us I have no
experience with women I don't know what
y'all do wait crazy for you for you okay
so you're modeling for your boyfriend
and you're like man I feel kind of fat
today
cuz you're cause you're very fit you
know exactly what your level of like
unfit or if it is yeah so if you feel a
little bit fat that day then if he goes
yeah you look a little bit flabby how
would you take it honestly I wouldn't
say that first of all second of all I
would just be quiet
really yes and if somebody was in front
of me looking in the mirror saying
something that was a fish I wouldn't say
anything I wouldn't lie I wouldn't agree
I would just sit in silence but then
that but that silence already says so
much why are you talking out loud just
press I might disagree with you ah
because we just need our friends to have
our back or a boyfriend Saveur back
little so gay guys can't read a girl's
mind understand women just like we are I
think the weight thing is very specific
but it's ready ask like about their hair
my friends I'd be like yo can you see my
nipples on this like yeah like you know
yeah do you okay so if I have a [ __ ]
up haircut but I really love it I really
love this haircut and it's [ __ ] up I
though so I got a haircut what do you
think
but you know I really love it do you I'm
gonna let you walk outside if I think
you look Buster you're a good friend
no it is a good friend but that's a
friend you lie I'm the most perfect
mysteries
you know what just happened to be here I
knew I should have been gay I'm leaving
with you
watch your abs like that it's just like
that cheesier to understand it Laurie
doesn't want you yeah it does maybe
[Music]